let's talk tv and a sitcom return for
ray romano
rachel smith is back from nashville and
apparently ray is a really good
company he sure is kev the cast of one
day at a time welcome to ray for their
big season premiere on cbs and it is
clear
everybody still loves raymond hi i'm
from the census
i think it was the first time that all
of us collectively as a cast were
absolutely starstruck because frey
is the royalty and you're the head of
the household
no what was so delicious about that
event
is how nervous we all were about having
ray romano on the set
no way yes we were nervous
justina was almost trembling with nerves
and i wasn't exactly relaxed either and
uh what is your age
i am ageless the reboot to the bonnie
franklin valerie bernelli and mackenzie
phillips classic
comes to cbs for its fourth season
starting tonight
following a successful netflix run
fine that should be easy to stay out of
something that does not exist
it's so excited because i know what an
incredible show it is and being on cbs
is such a big deal for us of course the
cast is rallying behind justina machado
as she competes on dancing with the
stars
we surprised her with this special
message from her tv mom and daughter
you are something else i'm so proud of
you
you're freaking killing it you are so
talented it's great
thank you i think that what's really
great is
rita such an icon and to like
have an icon like that it's like and my
daughter who's a superstar
i appreciate that thank you so much for
[Music]
that